[Music]
check this out we have a board game made
if you don't know it's called shady
agents you can go to the link right down
below and click that it's our
Kickstarter and only on our Kickstarter
we have this special edition that has
not safe for work questions and it's a
black and gold box it's really really
cool but it's only gonna be available
there you got to get it right now
because it's gonna end really soon okay
now on to our article video oh yeah oh
yeah that [ __ ] did well well done
well well advertised ever thank you very
Smith Thank You Dean you Satan who's
[ __ ] Satan Hey submitted by NBA
greater than NFL yeah [ __ ] right you
wish look at the numbers pal I think the
numbers to say that don't they it's more
internationally watch crushes these guys
and I felt Russia's dying but in the
world it's dialing no one's watching it
and people are getting paid less and
less that's like saying soccer is dying
because I don't want you to my house no
soccer is growing like no but soccer
sucks though soccer is for [ __ ] but
though NBA dude doesn't even come close
to the revenue that NFL gets doesn't
even come close
yeah dude Google issue everyone knows
that the Super Bowl commercials are very
expensive but then just think about just
think about the NBA Finals versus the
Super Bowl exactly it doesn't even come
close
don't even think about this two NBA
games know when a team sucks nobody's
there football games if the team sucks
the stains still packed so it's it's
that whole world washes and you know you
know what especially the Browns yeah cuz
the whole world watches NBA
he likes NBA debut popular over there
all right dude the idea of being a
Browns fan and sit in there for like a a
winless season but you go every Sunday
is amazing not if I could do it dude you
sit in a cold Tundra and you watch your
team lose every week Jeff it's
incredible maybe they won't lose that
hard this year like they that's what
they're it's like the porn were the guys
it's like the porn where the guys watch
their wives get [ __ ] and they just cry
in the corner and they like rapper
rapper little you know you all about it
rapper rapper lil Uzi vert told his fans
are gonna go to hell during a recent
concert so why does that suck hey isn't
he the devil don't some artists like pee
on their parents are Kelly dude there
was this one guy this guy named Gigi
Ellen who's like a punk rocker dude he
would take a [ __ ] on stage like pull
down his pants to get on stage you get
the [ __ ] and then fling it at people in
the audience and what are you prep for
that you just got to eat like three
burritos before you I don't know is he
famous enough worth you got hit in the
face with a [ __ ] you try to pick up yeah
sounds like just chimpanzee behavior to
me that's so specific good for you I
would have just said monkey and then I
would have [ __ ] up did he say
everybody was going to go to hell
because he's also going to hell yeah
that's cool that's not right so for
those of you that don't know a little
little boozy right if you like I follow
this fool doesn't have [ __ ] tats yep
a lot of them have that right oh yeah
yeah yeah okay yep I still follow him I
don't even know why I followed my ideas
somehow so people have heard of this guy
it's no new news to them that he's there
like there's a conspiracy saying that
he's the Satan and everybody's the same
what's that yeah what's the outrage like
what's wrong with saying everyone's
going to hell you guys
what's that I mean people just carried
everything I guess and it just stands
out to them is that the outrageous no
people are people are mad that they're
mad is just like putting pearls and [ __ ]
like what the coccyx the concert goers
in pearls what the [ __ ] does that mean
that's that like crunching pearls his
fans we're a lot of problem you know
it's really funny though it's like his
fans
so his fans he probably listen to his
music and know every lyric and know what
he's about but he crossed the line when
he said don't you going to hell that's
the point
let me tell you guys about what he's
known for right so if you say his name
fast nosy but what is that Lucifer yeah
something Lucifer Z to my trust Joe's
gonna put another hole in the wall who
doesn't like that game but I caught it
real quick doesn't really sound like
Lucifer lose the other path a little bit
that's one thing bluesy birth I guess I
can't like conspiracy head around it so
then another thing about his name is low
lil Uzi vert means a little Suzy
vertically which is shooting at gods
yeah it's like a lot of watch it's also
like a kick-ass July 4th celebration
that's all of East LA right there yeah
he's really patriotic he the fact that
he calls Marilyn Manson like his father
and then Marilyn's black understand this
Marilyn mad does not even satanic right
no yeah he's like I'm known yeah well I
thought he was like he's like : yeah I
thought it was this trolled satanic not
the real satanic yeah so he could suck
his own dick but he's a master troll we
found out so I thought that was real but
it's a whole bunch of people message
means like it's not true you won't give
me David why don't you do this I'm
saying dude it's like a ruined I got
really do
David yeah the NBA makes more money than
function nah dude actually was real bro
I'm sorry alright didn't suck his own
dick then you [ __ ] I thought so
too I thought it was real I thought so
too my whole childhood is like [ __ ]
upended that was like the fact that was
like an elementary school you know we
even tried googling it that one whole
episode and I couldn't find any
information couldn't print couldn't
prints just suck his own dick like I'm
normally without removing prints cut is
the only guy who could suck his own dick
and and it wouldn't be gay
and it wouldn't be gay thank you thank
you a bunch of dudes could be drinking
beer watching him and be like that's not
gay yeah he got Marilyn Manson he had a
change I love Marilyn Manson and Marilyn
Manson posted a photo of him with the
chain and said Lucifer rising in the
caption so that's like just that's bad
ball one yeah we've been that's our
friend Ben made it bit bad been made
that jewelry Oh for some reason I just
wouldn't I mean I never picture Satan
being a black dude you know what they
have to do to humanize this guy just
interview his grandma would you like oh
you mean Clarence yeah he peed his bad
all his mystique of oh this [ __ ] suit
it would just go out the window and you
get to know who he really is he shits in
the bed
he doesn't like [ __ ] broccoli you're
not saying you're too small he's like 5
foot 2 a lot of people are saying like
he's just saying all do all of this [ __ ]
just to like stir the pot and then get
more flip this publicity cuz his whole
thing is like is a it's like the whole
like 666 upside down crosses seeing that
he's going to hell so now I'm gonna show
you a video of when he's telling his
fans that they're gonna go to hell - for
listening to him
[Music]
right now yes No
Satan's not black and he's not like five
feet tall he's always a very thin sexy
white guy exactly and he wearing a black
coat always and he's always got a lizard
quality with the tail I pictured a goat
head with the human body or something
but he's only the white guy though oh
yeah I think has to be a white guy a
smooth white guy drinks like whiskey
let's bear refine and you can't really
tell yeah geez like the Dos Equis guy
yeah more refined than that guy's got a
rough run he always just looks like a
vampire
yeah and Jesus is not supposed to be
blind and that's what it's supposed to
be so maybe he's Jesus
someone else pointed out too is that it
says in the Bible somewhere that the
devil is gonna come back as a tortured
no as a very handsome man cuz the one
point about like he's he's good-looking
very very handsome guy yeah he's like
he's too small though like I'm like
legit if it was the rapture and Satan
came out as I'm coming for you and he's
like the size of this phone I mean he
would have any wood of the ammunition
gonna laugh at his face if shame came
back he wouldn't be a musician he'd be a
politician or a dictator or someone
important some people think it would be
a musician but musicians don't really
really have that kind of power
yeah because they also get raped by the
studio and we think about Michael
Jackson yeah I was about to say Michael
[ __ ] Jackson
change the world long yeah you still
can't Star Wars truth
that's true but he buddy I mean he can
get a lot of people I mean dude his
grave like wherever the [ __ ] it is
people go outside cuz he's like not
publicly buried like he's inside of a
building like in a mausoleum or whatever
the hell hi-yah and people go outside
the building and take pictures of a
[ __ ] window that's I'd be that person
too so I get it
right so that's what I'm saying we're
influenced by this man and this is a
different generation being influenced
you're watching him and going like
whatever but they're watching this guy
and going like yo that's like in the
music like I'm pretty sure if like this
dude Satan was gonna come out he
wouldn't have like people try to
interpret who he is - a - man like go
backwards Beatle records yeah approach
to the churches would probably would
have recognized this - they're just like
I was like you know do it is a thing you
know it's dope though that shows you
hip-hop made it like hip hop's big now
like it was never on this level where
like like cuz now I've got that tension
of Satan pop maybe yeah you've made it
congratulations I wonder like if most
these people are even like Protestant in
the first place so why would you [ __ ]
care that's true would you care if your
not even like a Christian Catholic or
whatever the [ __ ] you care if you say he
doesn't exist that what I love about
this those are like a lot of aging rock
groups out there that are pulling the
same kind of [ __ ] okay what the [ __ ]
we're doing this how come nobody pay
attention we've been doing this [ __ ]
dude I pierced the head of my dick last
week and my buddy here like he [ __ ]
like sucked it and then we he spit the
come out into a bucket that we put our
blood into it and mixed it up and on
stage and nobody [ __ ] cares TMZ the
[ __ ] right about it there's so many
rock bands that already did we must be
mad
yeah that's what sucks I mean but they
got a lot of publicity to raise I like
that some of them like the bigger one
like yeah like you're talking about the
Beatles I call my hello Rio they never
did that intentionally it was other
people that made it up wait the Beatles
never did want the the backwards record
thing that was like churches that made
it up didn't Paul McCartney remove his
roots we could suck somebody 100 percent
[ __ ] I can't believe that's not real I'm
legit it wasn't them that did it though
I wish I didn't come today so I could
just live with that fat just knowing
that I you know everything it's like a
Santa's not real to me it's like one of
those things that it's so clearly
ridiculous that it's not real it took it
blew up into something that became real
it's so weird but it's also one of those
things that now that I know the truth
I'm still gonna believe I'm stone keeps
fighting the line for my own person who
feels better than the I mean the lie
feels better than the truth yes as so
often happens
[Music]